Наша організація називається "Чачімо"
ромською мовою означає "правда", "істина".
Надаємо юридичну допомогу,
консультації ромам і не ромам.
Проходьте, будь ласка, це наш офіс. Він у нас невеличкий.
Наша діяльність
більш вона зараз направлена на інтеграцію ромів
і на захист прав ромів.
Коли в людей є стереотипи,
то вони через ці шаблони дивляться на всю громаду.
Якщо в людини є негативний досвід
цей досвід він проектує на всіх людей.
А я сам, особисто,
я зустрічався з такими і зустрічаюсь.
І коли я кажу "ром", багато людей не вірять,
кажуть " ти не ром". Я кажу "а чому ви так вирішили?"
Кажуть, "в нас досвід є негативний". В ромів нема своєї країни.
Розумієте? В них нема консульства свого.
Тому ми і кажем "ми є українці"
Ми — українці як й інші. Живем на цій землі.
Це наша земля.
Мої пращури тут живуть 500 років.
Ми всі перемішані. Ми змішались.
Наші культури, наші мови,
у нас невістки українки, розумієте?
В нас розмовляють і українською мовою, і російською,
і ромською мовою.
І тому я вважаю, що це все штучно.
Ви знаєте, в мене був такий невеличкий досвід.
Я хотів орендувати квартиру
І коли я пішов в агентство, мені сказали
"Ви знаєте, молодий чоловіче, з вашим обличчям дуже складно знайти квартиру"
А потім мені сказали: "Але є один варіант".
І ми поїхали. Коли ми приїхали,
виходить господар, дивиться на мене
і каже: "А якої ви національності?"
Ну, а взагалі, роми вони вийшли із Індії.
Тому я кажу:"Ви знаєте.."
(я йому російською відповів)"Ви знаєте мої предки вони вийшли з Індії"
Він мені каже:"Оооо, знаєте, індусів в нас ще не було, проходьте."
Зараз найактуальніше питання — це захист прав ромів
Питання ромів і ставлення до ромів у суспільстві, на мою думку,
вони відзеркалюють ті процеси, які взагалі проходять в нашому суспільстві.
І ставлення до ромів зараз, як на мене, це індикатор
Індикатор того, що взагалі діється в нашому суспільстві.
Тому я хочу, і моя мрія, щоб ромські діячі вони йшли в політику,
щоб вони були в органах самоврядування,
щоб вони представляли ті інтереси, які є в ромській громаді.
Дуже багато молоді, яка зараз має вищу освіту,
і я розумію, що це завтрішній час
Моя мрія в тому, щоб роми були не тільки по факту громадяни,
щоб вони були патріоти своєї країни,
які дивляться на світ не тільки як роми,
а як громадяни України.
Зараз наша діяльність пов'язана більше з самоорганізацією ромської громади
Ми десь знаходимо 10-12 активних людей в ромській громаді,
ми для них проводимо тренінги
щодо правах людини,
як спілкуватись з органами влади...
Зараз ми проводили тренінги у Вовчанську,
ми проводили тренінги для РДА,
районної адміністрації,там були різні служби.
І, знаєте, коли ми проводили,
І люди казали "Ми багато що знаємо про ромів",
Але коли ми проводили ці тренінги,
коли ми казали про ментальність, про культуру,
як будувати відносини з цими людьми,
то люди кажуть: "Це дуже цікаво,нам це подобається.
А для ромів ми проводимо інші тренінги:
щоб люди розуміли що таке держава,
що таке право,
які права в людини є, як вони можуть реалізувати свої права,
яка відповідальність громадянина України, розумієте?
І тому ми розуміємо, що тут людям потрібно знати про ромів
а ромам більше потрібно знати про державу
і про те, що таке громадяни держави.
Тому зараз в нас більша направленість на те,
щоб в ромських громадах було самоврядування.
І я думаю, що сепаратизм починається з цього:
коли країну ділять на ромів, не ромів,
коли країну ділять на інші національності
Коли ми кажемо : "Я — ром"
Я — ром, але я українець, це моя земля,
тут живе моя родина,
тут люди, мої друзі і я — українець.
Та, я не такий білий як всі,
трошки лисуватий, але я українець.